[MUSIC PLAYING]
GREG BRAIL: Hello.
Welcome.
My name is Greg Brail.
I'm here also with
Keith Danekind.
And together, we're going to
talk about APIs and how people
use APIs to create connected
digital experiences to create
new lines of business,
new product areas,
new things out of APIs, and
out of all kinds of technology.
We're going to start out
with some examples about how
people actually have used
APIs to solve real business
problems.
Then we're going to talk
a little bit about what
this means by showing you
a demo of what it means
to be a consumer of an API.
Then we'll go into some more
detail about the technology.
And after we do
that, we're going
to have another demo,
which is going to show you
how you actually
use Apigee in order
to actually create and
manage these APIs programs.
And finally, we'll have time
at the end for questions.
So if you do have questions, I
know there's ways in the tool
that you can actually do
that while we're talking.
And we'll be getting
to those at the end,
so don't be surprised if we
don't address them right away.
So I wanted to
start off by talking
about interesting
things that businesses
have done around the world,
primarily using APIs.
And there are some really
interesting aspects here.
So for instance, if
we look at Starbucks.
They put in their annual report
that 13% of their revenue
comes through mobile apps.
Those mobile apps are not built
on completely new technology
infrastructure
that never existed
before because Starbucks has
a big infrastructure already.
Instead, what they
did is they used APIs.
And the mobile
apps talk to APIs.
And the APIs then
give the mobile apps
just what they need to
give a really good user
experience to those apps
based on Starbucks' existing
technology.
Other examples,
for instance, are
Swisscom, which has
actually been offering
APIs as a service for some of
their network infrastructure
in Switzerland.
Or Arity, which is part
of the insurance business.
It used to be, in order to bring
a business partner on board,
they would have a three
to four month process
of negotiation, emailing,
Microsoft Word docs,
all that kind of fun stuff.
Now with APIs, they allow
their business partners
to get on board with their
business-to-business services
within a few days, completely
within self-service.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about why that's important,
and why that's a big part
of everyone's API programs.
The way people use APIs
and use API management--
because this talk is also
going to be a lot about API
management and what it means--
is we've been doing
this for a while.
I've been part of
Apigee since 2007.
We weren't talking
about APIs back then,
but we started soon after.
And a lot of customers who come
into this world of APIs and API
management, they start off
with a point to point problem.
My goodness, we need to launch
an app for iPhone and Android.
And we don't have any
technology in our existing
system that can
actually talk over
the internet to those devices.
How am I actually
going to connect
these mobile devices and
all these kinds of things
to my legacy systems?
And that's where
we started to see,
five or six years ago,
people doing basic web APIs
with API management.
Using API keys in order to
protect access to an existing
service, implementing
things like OAuth,
putting things like
quotas in place
in order to protect
access to the internet.
But where things have gotten
really more interesting
recently, and the
companies that have
had the most interesting
successes with APIs,
are people who are
creating differentiating
digital experiences.
That is, people are creating
new ways of doing business,
not only through mobile
apps, but through things
like digital assistants, which
we see all over the place
nowadays.
And the real fun
comes when people
are able to actually transform
their business models
and create new
ecosystems and turn
their companies into platforms
that other people can
do business on.
And I'm going to talk about
a few examples of those.
A great example here is Magalu.
If you're not
familiar, they actually
used to be called
Magazine Luiza.
They're the largest
retailer in Brazil.
And they have been
a brick and mortar
retailer for a very long time.
And what they've done
over the last few years
is they started to change
into more of a platform
that third parties use
to do commerce in Brazil.
They obviously have a
huge infrastructure.
They have a huge
physical infrastructure.
And they started off with
that basic task of creating
new digital experiences.
Hey, we need mobile apps.
We want to be able
to offer e-commerce.
But it quickly pivoted
into actually, now
they have about--
well, about 100 APIs.
But they have thousands
of partners and suppliers
who use their
platform to do things
like sell products using
their infrastructure,
ship using their supply chain.
Very much like Amazon
in the US became
not just an online store,
but a platform for e-commerce
that thousands and
probably even more,
producers and consumers
use to transact business.
Magalu is doing the
same thing in Brazil.
They're sort of becoming
the Amazon of Brazil,
which is ironic because Brazil
already had one of those.
But now they have
a digital one too.
Another great example
is Accuweather.
Everyone knows Accuweather
because some of us
still watch TV sometimes, and
our weather information-- also,
our weather information on our
various mobile apps and things
and on the web-- comes
from Accuweather.
They have a
well-deserved reputation
for giving excellent
weather forecasts.
They process about $50
billion API requests a day.
And the vast
majority of them are
from the weather
app on your phone
or your watch or your
refrigerator or whatever,
right?
But what Accuweather
also does is
they have some high
volume forecast products
because long-term
weather forecasting is
very important in a
lot of industries.
Financial services, oil
and gas, agriculture, these
depend greatly on long-term,
very accurate weather
forecasts.
That's what Accuweather
is known for.
And those forecast products
are pretty valuable.
So Accuweather has
whole tiers of APIs.
And they have ways in order
to bring business partners
on board with those
higher value APIs
to actually charge them the
value of that interesting data
that they're giving
them, and also
to keep track of
who's using the API.
And one more example
is Ticketmaster.
We all know Ticketmaster
because that's
where you go when you
want to buy a ticket.
They, of course, have a
mobile app and a website
and all those kinds of things.
But they also-- one thing
that not everyone knows--
is Ticketmaster
actually offers APIs
that allow third parties
to transact business
and to buy tickets
on Ticketmaster.
And in 2016, actually, which
was a little while back,
but 10% of their ticket sales
came from those partners.
And some of those partners
are things like Costco.
You can buy tickets at Costco.
But there are other aspects
where people have integrated
Ticketmaster into apps.
So for instance, you just
bought plane tickets.
So where would you
like to buy tickets?
You bought plane
tickets to New York.
Do you want to go see "Harry
Potter and the Cursed Child"
while you're there?
A travel app for a travel
site, for instance,
can now use the Ticketmaster
API to integrate that directly
into their app without
jumping out to a completely
different digital experience.
So what kind of holds
all these together?
It's that all these various
companies are not only
using APIs to solve
business problems,
but they're not looking APIs
purely as a bit of technology.
They're looking at
the API as something
that is for a customer.
They're looking at
it as a product.
And I think that's where
things get really interesting.
And that's where APIs get really
successful is when you don't
just think of it is, how are
we going to get the technology
to get the JSON to the mainframe
that's going to look at the XML
and talk to the SAP?
But how are we actually
going to create something
that developers are
going to want to use.
So for instance, Magalu
deals with retail partners.
So their API product managers--
and big successful APIs
have product managers-- have
to think about questions like,
what kind of technology
do these retailers use?
What data formats
can they handle?
How are they connected
to the internet?
What sort of things do
they need to do in order
to actually access these APIs?
Similarly, Accuweather,
Ticketmaster, and we've
all been there.
Most of us are developers
or we've developed software
and we know what we
like and we don't like.
And what I've always said about
developers for a long time
is that developers aren't lazy,
but developers are in a hurry.
And they have a
very, very fast way
of telling by
looking at something,
is this something I
want to engage with?
Is this something I want
to spend my time on?
Or is this something
that's completely off
in a different direction and
is going to be a waste of time
or is going to require me to
pull in a bunch of technology
that I don't actually need?
The great thing
about APIs is that it
was based on a very, very simple
technology base of HTTP, JSON,
OAuth, TLS, technologies that
are already prevalent anywhere.
So that a developer who
wants to learn to do an API
doesn't need to install
a giant tech stack,
but can actually get started
right away using technology
they probably already know.
So what we've seen between
projects and products
is that it's really about--
even looking at things
like what is your revenue?
What is your CSAT for your API?
What are your lead
generation capabilities?
Is there someone who is looking
every week at how many people
have signed up to use the API?
How has API traffic
changed over time?
Have new people started
to come on board?
Have people who have
been customers before
stopped using the API?
There are a lot of
interesting things
that have to happen there.
It's just like running
any other digital product.
And with that said,
we're actually
going to start
with a demo of what
it looks like to be
a consumer of an API.
What does it look like
to discover an API,
look at the documentation
for the API, sign up the API,
and get started.
So Keith is going to show us
his demo system right now.
KEITH DANEKIND: Thanks, Greg.
OK.
So for the demo,
we're going to look
at this from three different
perspectives; the application
developer, the API
developer, and the API team.
So the application
developer or API consumer
might be saying things
like, all I want to do
is build an application.
Make it easy for me to
consume your services.
The API developer, who's taking
services and packaging them up
so that that application
developer can use them,
that person might
be saying, I need
to share a service
with other people.
But there's some limits.
We have to control
what they can do.
The API team who's
running the API program,
they may be saying
something like, I
want to think about API
as a software products.
There's customers, there's
life cycles, there's versions.
I want to measure my program
and I want to tune it.
So in this case,
I'm going to play
the role of the application
developer or API consumer.
And in this case,
one of our suppliers
has a large ERP system.
And we place orders
with them, and we'd
like to check on the
status of those orders.
And this is a somewhat time
consuming process right now.
They've granted us an API
to be able to go speed up
that process and automate
this, and to integrate
that information into our
internal tracking applications.
So let's see what it looks like
to use the Order Management
and Order Tracking APIs.
So here's their
developer portal.
And what I want
to learn about is
how to track the
status of an order
if I have an order number.
So let's see what
they have here.
Get Started.
Get a key and test out the APIs.
Learn about and try our APIs.
So well, how do you get started?
Get started in 3 steps.
Sign in, register apps,
access the API keys.
OK.
That sounds easy enough.
Let's see what the APIs are.
Looks like there is a
order status tracker here,
and someone's written
some nice documentation
to make this easy for me.
So I call a URL, I put an order
number at the end of there.
I'm going to need to supply an
API key and an order number,
and I should be able
to make this work.
I'll get back some data
that looks like this.
So that's pretty good.
I have a reasonable idea
of how this might work.
I'm going to go
register for an API key,
and I'm going to test this out.
So I come over to here, and
I'm going to click on Apps.
I'm going to register
a new application.
And we use this
order tracking API.
When I create this, it'll
register my application
and it'll give me an API key.
So now that we have
that key, let's
go back to the documentation
and try it out.
I'll put the key in there.
We'll grab a sample
order number.
And there we go.
That's what the
results look like.
So I see the data is
in here, and that's
what I would expect to be
returned when I call this API.
Easy enough to do.
Let's build an application.
So here's a simple order
status tracking application.
You put an order number
in here, press search,
and we get back some
status of this order.
So we get all the details there.
Very easy to write this, took
me about 15 minutes or so.
And best thing
was, I didn't need
to have any knowledge of what's
on the back end system, how
this order system on
the other end works.
I just had a simple API to call
in and it returned that data.
I built a single page web
application and put it in here.
It'd be easy to embed this
in any kind of application.
So that's the demo from the
perspective of the API consumer
or application developer.
Next, let's look at this from
the API product manager's
point of view.
What is it like to
manage this API program?
So let's see how our
API program is running.
To do that, I'm logged
into the Apigee experience.
I'm going to come over and
click on the Analyze button.
And from there, I see a
bunch of different reports
I can look at.
Let's look at a few
of these and see
what we can find out about how
the API program is running.
This first report shows
us proxy performance,
and we can see how
much traffic we've
gotten in the last hour or so.
And we'll see a few people,
who looks like they're probably
getting rate limited.
We see average
response time in here,
we see traffic by proxy and
average response time by proxy.
So this is a good overall
operational metric,
just telling us how our
API program is running.
So this report shows
developer engagement.
What we're seeing
in here is there's
a total of 10 developers, 7 of
them have apps, 4 are active,
and we've got 1
that's highly active.
So this gives us an idea of
how engaged our developers are.
We can see which devices
people are using.
This might influence how we
support different clients
and things like that.
So we can see who's on
mobile, who's on desktop,
and then what kind of
browsers they're using.
The GeoMap shows us where
people are calling from.
So if we click in and zoom
in on the United States here,
we can see that there's a lot
of traffic from California
and some is coming
from Colorado.
This is a custom report that
shows us order status format.
So this API will return data
in XML format or JSON format,
depending on what type of
accept header you send.
So if you put application
JSON as the accept type,
it'll return JSON data.
If you put application
XML in the header,
it'll return XML data.
And that was to support
some older clients.
It's interesting, from the
company's point of view,
to see how people
are using this.
The XML interface is
a legacy interface,
and we want to see
who's still using that.
So this gives us an idea over
time of who's calling what
and what they're
doing with it, so we
get an idea of what
kind of responses
people are interested in.
And we could look at
that trend over time.
And it'll show us--
we can compare that
to a previous period.
So this'll look at the
previous hour versus this hour.
We can compare the two periods.
So you can build custom
reports in Apigee
to do anything you want.
You can grab data
that Apigee stores,
and you can grab anything out
of the request or response
and build your own
custom report for that.
So using these
analytics reports,
building your own
custom reports,
gives you some good
insights into how
your API program is running.
GREG BRAIL: OK, thanks.
So what Keith showed
you was not only
what does an API look like
as the consumer of an API,
but what does the API
product manager actually do?
How does that API
product manager
keep track of who's using
the API, and control that.
So now I want to talk a little
bit about the technology
under the covers,
and what are some
of the technical
considerations you
have to put into
place if you want
to successfully offer an API
for lots and lots of people.
So it all starts with
digital consumer management,
or really the management of
who is consuming your API.
You could just call
this API management.
And what we find in the
industry is that a lot of people
know the terms API management,
and a lot of people
know the terms API gateway, and
they use them interchangeably.
And actually, when we
talk about API management,
we're talking about this
thing here that Apigee
has used many times in the past
that we call the digital value
chain.
But the really important thing
about this from our perspective
is that this is about
managing the relationship
between the API producers
over there on the right who
are creating that API, those
product managers, architects,
engineers who have
created the API.
And then over to the
left of the API consumer,
that's the actual developer who
is building an app, otherwise
known as a digital experience,
that's going to use that API.
So API consumer
management is all
about managing
that relationship.
So what Keith showed
you in the demo was
he showed you both
the API consumer
side of that relationship as
well as the API producer side.
What does it mean to actually
be a person who manages the API?
And then later on,
in the next demo,
we'll get into
the details of how
do the API consumers actually
use an API management
product to make all of
those things happen.
I'll talk about a few
other technologies
that are really, really
important here as well.
One of them is OAuth.
OAuth is-- I know we're
jumping into technology
all of a sudden, and this
might seem a little abrupt.
But this is a really important
part of API management
because what's happened in
the industry over the last six
or seven years is that OAuth
has become the standard for API
authentication.
It's not just the
de facto standard.
It's an actual set
of IETF standards,
which makes it a real standard.
And it's used by
almost everybody.
Whenever you are using Google
or Facebook or Twitter or,
maybe not Amazon, but
almost everything out there.
Whenever you get to one of
those pages that says sign in
or any time you do sign in with
Google, sign in with Facebook,
sign in with GitHub,
you're using OAuth.
OAuth was originally
designed to solve a browser
single sign on problem.
But OAuth, since
then, has actually
been used very often for
mobile authentication
and for authentication
of all kinds of devices.
And the reason it's important
is because at the end
of the whole OAuth process,
what the device ends up
with is a token, which
is a bit of stuff that
may have some structure
to it or might just
be a set of random numbers.
Some sort of gateway,
which I have down here
on the bottom, an
API gateway, needs
to actually
authenticate and decide
whether or not to allow
access to the API.
And then how that
token is produced
can now vary depending on
the business requirements.
So for instance, it can be as
simple as popping open a form
where you type in your
username and password.
Or it could involve two
factor authentication,
physical security
tokens, consent screens--
those screens we all know
and love that say, hey,
do you give application
x the permission
to see your email address and
look at all of your friends?
That's all the OAuth
protocol and related aspects
like OpenID Connect make
all of that stuff happen.
The important part
about this is that we
have a couple of parts
of OAuth that are there.
One of them is the API gateway,
which actually enforces, where
you have to have a
proper token in order
to access these services.
Another is what's called
the authorization server.
Products like Apigee can act
as an authorization server,
but so can many others.
And then API management
is a really important part
of OAuth-- because what
technologists don't understand
right away is that OAuth is not
only end user authentication,
it's Greg using my API.
It's also application
authentication.
Greg is making an API call
from version 7 of the iPhone
app for the package tracking API
and for the API products named
package tracker.
That allows the
API product manager
to know who is using the API.
And it allows the people
responsible for security
to know things
like, an popped up
that we didn't know about that's
creating a lot of traffic.
Or we accidentally pushed
out a bad release of the app.
It's got a problem.
You have to take all the
API calls from that app
and wrap them and send
them off somewhere else.
Or worst case
scenario, a developer
signed up for the API.
They're using the
API in a way that's
inconsistent with
our terms of service.
We have to stop that application
from using our API right away.
These are all things
that happen a lot
in the world of API management.
And they're possible because
the OAuth authorization
server is very tightly coupled
with the API management system.
Another thing that happens a lot
on APIs is the idea of a quota.
Quotas were part of the
very first public web APIs.
And they exist because
if you're going
to let people you don't
trust use your API,
you have to have some way to
control how much they use it.
Otherwise, they can
cause big, big production
problems for you.
You don't want to
be in a situation
where someone signed up for your
API, and if you have no OAuth,
you might not know what
application is using the API.
But even if you do,
without a quota,
you don't want them to drive
API usage to such a point
that it produces
denial of service
for your other customers.
Now there is a whole range of
traffic management strategies
you have to put in place when
you put an API on the Internet.
DDOS, for instance,
the kind of classic TCP
distributed denial
of service attacks
that we all have heard
about from botnets.
Those actually, to
a certain degree,
have to be handled at the
network level, at the IP level.
And the big Cloud
providers, for instance,
have sophisticated
technology for this,
as does anyone who runs a lot
of volume on the internet.
Similarly, we have
to have things
like rate limits in
routers and gateways
that control you know,
hey, this bit of technology
really is going to
fall apart if it
handles more than 10,000
concurrent requests.
The quota is more
of a business limit.
It controls which application
is allowed to use the API
and how much.
Without a quota, you can't
really have self-service.
You can't let just anyone
sign up for your API
if you can't control
how much they use it.
And it's not only because people
might do nefarious things,
but also because you need
to protect against people
making dumb mistakes.
Hey, someone accidentally
pushed out a version of the API.
Whenever it sees an error,
it retries immediately
with no delay.
Great, if you have
a quota, at least
you can protect yourself
from that kind of API,
from that sort of
bad access pattern.
Similarly, a quota also
makes it possible to have
business relationships, to have
different tiers of service.
Keith's API, for
instance, he might
want to say that for free,
you get a very low quota.
But if you're a giant
website and you're
going to be driving thousands
of requests a second to the API,
you need a quota so that we can
control how much you use it.
APIs also face all kinds of
interesting security threats.
Many of these are things
that are familiar to you
if you've done anything
else on the web.
But there are some
things that might
be a little bit unique to API,
so we need to think about.
So for instance, if
you're opening an API up
to a third party and you're
letting your third party post
JSON or XML or
anything else to you,
you're basically letting anyone
who can sign up on the internet
send arbitrary content
to your server.
Now depending on what
technology you have behind it
and what the format
is, that data
that can be sent to
your server could
contain all kinds of things.
In theory, it could contain
things like viruses,
but more likely,
someone might try
to do something like send
you a JSON document that's
nested a million levels deep.
Or send you a JSON document
with a string in it
that's 100 megabytes long.
And these kinds of things
could actually cause problems
to your back ends, depending
on what kind of technology
stack they implement,
and how robust they are.
API gateways like Apigee do
have efficient ways to inject
those kinds of things
before they get in.
There's other things too,
things like SQL injection,
things like--
Google has a service called
data loss prevention, which
can look at the responses
to your API calls
and make sure that you're
not inadvertently sending out
people's social security
numbers or credit card numbers
or things like that.
So there's a whole
lot of threats
that APIs face, some of
which are specific to APIs.
And that, we want to make sure
we address in the API as well.
And one more thing
that comes up,
it's not necessary
for every API,
but it becomes very important
in the world of APIs,
is the concept of mediation
and transformation.
And this is where
so many companies--
we started out earlier
on with a slide
where we showed that people
progress from a simple point
to point integration
scenario to something
that was more
sophisticated where they
were building a new platform.
But almost everyone who starts
out in the world of APIs
has some sort of
technology already.
And if you're in
the kind of shop
where you can rewrite everything
and you could make changes
and you have enough
flexibility in your tech stack,
that's awesome.
You could do whatever you
need when you need to do it.
But people who have
built up their businesses
over a period of
years, typically
don't always have that
kind of flexibility
everywhere on their tech stack.
So it can sometimes be
very important to be
able to layer an API in
front of other services.
And those services
may vary in how close
they are to the API you
actually want to offer.
Many businesses have
mainframes, and those mainframes
aren't going away any time soon.
[INAUDIBLE] has SAP,
Salesforce, they
have SOAP web services
that were built
in the heyday of the SOAP era.
They have Node JS apps that
might speak very, very well
structured, beautifully
structured APIs, and JSON,
it might just be a mess.
The API gateway is
often used in order
to sort of mediate those legacy
systems and transform things.
Transform
JSON into XML, transform
JSON into GRPC,
transform JSON into a
format that might be easier
to parse for the app.
An API gateway can perform a
very important use case there.
Another thing that
API gateways do,
which is actually
even more common,
is they act as a
virtualization layer.
So if I look on my lower
right hand corner there,
we have a collection
of microservices.
And if you're doing
microservices the way
that people who are really
into microservices want to do,
the whole idea is that that
collection of microservices
could have five microservices
or 50 services or 5,000
microservices.
And it really shouldn't matter
to the consumer of the API
how that's done.
The whole point of
microservices is
that the teams that
own those services are
free to rearrange them and
change them and implement them
on the technology
base they want.
And they should be able to
do that without everyone
knowing about it.
So it would be a big
disaster if your system made
of 50 microservices was
structured in such a way
that all of your
customer's API clients
had to change when you wanted
to split that up to now
100 different microservices.
So one very important
things API gateways
do in microservices
architecture is they
act as a virtualization point.
They present a
consistent interface,
a set of HTTP, URIs, and verbs,
your URI patterns and verbs
more specifically, that are
consistent and stable and
well-documented and presented
to that end user application.
And then that API gateway,
behind the covers,
can change as the actual
technology implementation
changes, maybe as
legacy systems are
replaced with real
systems or new systems.
In an addition, when
microservices or environments
are refactored, that
API gateway can also
act as that
virtualization layer.
And with that said, I
want to talk quickly
about Google's API management
and API gateway products.
Then we're going to
get into one more demo.
Google, in the world of APIs,
if you go to the Google Cloud
Console, you'll actually see
that we have two major product
families.
Right now we have a product
called Cloud Endpoints.
Cloud Endpoints
is an API gateway,
and it's only an API gateway.
The advantage of Cloud Endpoints
is that it's small, it's cheap,
and it's very well
suited for applications
where you have very basic
needs for an API gateway
that you can deploy quickly,
especially to Google Cloud.
Google Cloud Endpoints
will run anywhere.
Cloud Endpoints can interact
with some of the other API
infrastructure already
built into Google Cloud,
so you can authenticate an
API call with an API key,
for instance.
Or you can use a
service account token,
which if you've work with GCP,
you're very familiar with.
And it's great for
those use cases.
We also have Apigee.
And Keith and I spent most
of our time on Apigee.
Apigee is a full lifecycle
API management product.
It's not only a gateway that can
do the various simple gateway
things that Endpoints
can do, as well as
a more sophisticated
gateway that can even
do some of the transformation
and mediation things
I talked about.
It's also got attached to
it a whole API management
platform that allows API product
managers and others to keep
track of what API
products they've created,
tie them to documentation.
Control who's actually
allowed to use those products,
what they're allowed to
do, set individual quotas
for different consumers.
Use role-based access control to
control what kind of consumers
can see which APIs, which
API calls they can make,
what talks they can see.
It's [INAUDIBLE] real designed
for the complete enterprise
lifecycle of an API program.
And that is, I
think in my opinion,
equally relevant if you're
offering an API on the internet
to third party
developers as it is
if you're a large
or even medium sized
organization that wants to offer
internal APIs that are consumed
by lots of different teams.
And this is actually a
picture of that platform.
We talk about some
of the components
of the platform including
developer portals, which
are sort of the key user
facing presence for your API,
as well as some of the
interesting analytics
we can give that we showed
you earlier in the demo.
As well as a lot of
services, including
transformation,
security, orchestration,
and those kinds of things.
One other thing I will
mention about Apigee
is that Apigee actually has
a couple different deployment
options.
This is a very frequently
asked question,
so we like to talk about
it in the beginning.
The Apigee Edge platform
runs as software
as a service as part
of Google Cloud, which
means that the API gateway
runs inside Google Cloud.
It can sit in between clients
and servers really anywhere.
And the whole API
management platform
is run by Google Cloud.
However, we offer
other options as well.
For instance, there
is a hybrid option
in which you're
allowed to have parts
of the Apigee gateway
running in your data center
with the rest of Apigee
running in Cloud.
And there's an on
premises option,
where everything runs in your
own space managed by you.
And that can mean your
own physical data center,
your own Amazon Web Services
account, your own Google Cloud
account, your own Azure account.
And we've had customers do
all of those kinds of things.
So with that said,
we're actually
going to go back to
the very last demo.
Keith is going to show us
some of the details of Apigee
and how to use it to
actually add API management
to an existing service.
KEITH DANEKIND: So we saw
how people call the API,
and we saw how people
manage the API program,
and how they build programs
and things like that.
But how do we get the
service up and running?
What do we do in Apigee
to make this work?
So the order service
is a cloud function
that's running a Google Cloud.
And in order to
use it, you've got
to send in an
authorization header.
And the credentials for that
are stored inside of Apigee.
On the left hand side of this,
there's a single page web
application that you saw.
It has an API key that
was generated by Apigee.
And there's a few more mobile
applications, all of them
have their own API key.
That lets me track
who's calling.
And it does something else.
There's a few
fields that show up
if you're using an
internal API key, that
don't show up if you're
using an external API key.
And the idea is people
inside the company
might need to know who the
sales team was that fulfilled
this order, but
that's not something
you want to share with
the outside people.
So when this runs
through Apigee,
if you're using a
particular API key,
it will remove that information.
And that gives the
right information
to the right people.
So one URL for everybody,
and different API products
to manage who can see what.
So the idea was, we want to
build a facade in the back end.
The fact that this
is a cloud function
or what's running
back there really
isn't that important
to the experience.
And we want to control
access to some features.
So some of that data,
we might want to remove.
And they only get
a small portion
of what might be available
through a real order tracking
system or through a whole
ERP system back there.
We want to put
some rate limits on
there so that people don't
call this excessively,
and impose some quotas.
Internal people can call it
a certain number of times,
and external people also
have their own quotas.
We want to add caching.
So I put a 5 minute
cache on here.
Somebody checks the
order again and again,
it'll just grab
that from memory.
And there's a five minute
time to live on that cache.
I wanted to reformat the request
and the response a little bit.
It's mostly good, but
I wanted to remove
a few fields in there.
So those are different things
you might do with Apigee
in a situation like this.
So let's look into
what I built in here.
So when I went to
build the API, I
started off with an
existing service.
So this is just a cloud
function that I can call.
And we'll take a look
at what it returns.
So we hit the URL, we
put the order number
on the end of there, and we get
back some basic data in here
that shows us about the order.
So that's nice.
And I wanted to control
access to this through Apigee.
And I also wanted to remove
this sales group field,
depending on whether you're
internal or external.
And I also wanted
to support XML.
The internal service
returns JSON,
but some external consumers
are still using XML
and they wanted to get
data in XML format.
So here's the API,
and this is what
it would look like if we
consumed it through Apigee.
So what we'll notice in here
is that field has disappeared.
And we can request XML or JSON.
So in this case, it's JSON.
But if I send a different header
in there, we get back XML.
There it is formatted.
So, same data,
but in XML format.
And that's going to support
clients who are currently
living in the XML world.
So other things we
could do with this.
I've got two different API keys.
I'm sending API key
as a URL parameter.
And depending on which one I
use, I get back an extra field.
So this is the API key that's
intended for external people.
And then if I switch
to this other API key
and make the call
again, we'll notice
that sales group shows up.
And that was the
field that I wanted
to hide from outside people.
So you can hand out
different API keys.
And this is
personalized, it's going
to give you the right
response to the right person.
And I'll show how I
did that in Apigee.
So that's the data
that comes back.
Let's look at the
actual API and what
I had to do to turn this
regular service into something
that I could manage with Apigee.
So let's look at
the API proxy that I
built to make this happen.
So I've logged into
the Apigee experience,
and I'm going to play the
role of API developer.
So I have that
existing service, I
want to manage access
to it using Apigee.
So I came over to API Proxies.
From here, you can
create a new proxy.
But what we're
going to do is we'll
look at this border status
proxy and see what's in there.
So there's the back end URL.
And there's the URL in Apigee
that we're going to call.
So we call Apigee.
It manages this connection,
the request and response flow.
It's going to send
it on to here,
and then we'll get
the response back.
So we'll click over
here on Develop.
And we'll see within
our flow, we've
got a few different steps.
So these different policies
do different things.
You can configure
them to do things.
There's a whole palette
of them right over here.
So let's look at
what I've added.
I've added a verify
API key check.
So I'm going to
look in the request
for a query parameter
called API key,
and that's what I'm going
to check for API keys.
If we don't send one,
we're going to get back
an unauthorized error.
Spike arrest is going to limit
this to 100 calls per minute.
You can set that to
whatever you like,
and that's just to
protect our back end.
And then we saw in
the report that I
was able to tell whether
somebody was requesting
XML data or JSON data.
I did that with the
statistics collector.
I'm grabbing the
accept header, and I'm
recording that as request type.
And then I can put that
in my custom report.
I've got a response
cache in here,
and the response cache has
a 300 second time to live.
And then the key has two
different fragments to it.
So I wanted to do
it off of the URI.
And that worked quite
well, but then I
figured out that I was
caching the wrong type of data
for the wrong type of person.
So it's possible that
people send in the same URL,
but one of them gets XML back
and one of them gets JSON back.
So we also have to look at
the accept type in the header
to make sure we send
back the right response,
and that it gets
cached correctly.
The back end system requires
an authorization header.
I've got the secrets for that
stored in a key value map
inside of Apigee.
So what this will do is it'll
go grab the order status
authentication code
from the key value map
and store it in a variable.
And then we set that
as an authorization
header that we're going
to send to the back end,
and that lets us in.
On the way back, we're going
to conditionally remove
the sales group.
And I've got some JavaScript
in there to do that.
So this makes a reference
to remove-sales-group.js.
And right down here,
three lines of JavaScript.
Very simple.
So we're going to
grab the response
and turn it into an
object in JavaScript.
And then we're just going to
delete the field, sales group.
And then we're going
to take that object
and turn it back into a string.
And then we're going to
replace the outgoing response
content with that new,
improved response.
After that, this will
get called conditionally.
So based on whether they've
had that header or not,
we'll convert it
to XML or we won't.
And then we've got
core support in here
so that we can call
this from the browser.
So that's our basic API proxy.
Wasn't too bad to build.
OK, let's do some questions.
GREG BRAIL: Someone said
restricting application
to certain APIs.
There's actually multiple
levels of which you might
want access control, right?
If you're using,
for instance, OAuth,
to protect access to an API,
then to a certain degree,
it's up to what
user authentication
system is behind
your OAuth as to what
end users can use your API.
But the thing that Apigee,
and any API management tool,
gives you is the
ability to control
what applications
can use your API,
and which developers can
build an application.
So you can set
controls on who is
allowed to build an
application for a specific API.
You can even set
controls in Apigee
on, for instance, who's allowed,
and to see documentation
for API and find out
which APIs exist.
There are a lot of things
in there based on things
we've learned about that.
KEITH DANEKIND: Right.
GREG BRAIL: We always
get the latency question.
And the answer is, it depends.
When Apigee runs as a
service, the actual proxy
runs in a Google
Cloud data center.
We have a lot of those.
They also happen to be very,
very close to Amazon data
centers, and very
well connected.
So if your target is in the
same region or very close
or in the same
geographical area,
then it depends on what
you do with the policies.
But it's no more than
a few milliseconds
plus network latency.
If your data center is on an
aircraft carrier in the South
Pacific being
connected by satellite,
then it's going to
have a lot of latency.
KEITH DANEKIND: Sure.
And yeah, so the when
I was writing, just
as an example, this demo,
I had a cloud function
running on the back end.
And I was seeing about 300
millisecond response time.
And that was just network
between me and the data center.
And I saw that cut in half
once I added caching to it.
So if you had caching, you may
find that the performance can
be drastically increased
because we don't have
to talk to the back end at all.
So, a few strategies
to deal with that.
GREG BRAIL: Exactly.
Someone asked about
Cloud Endpoints.
I should actually
talk about that
since that's a big
part of my life.
Cloud Endpoints
and Apigee, today,
do different things for
different customers.
So for instance,
Cloud Endpoints is
very handy for sharing an API
with other Google Cloud users,
and runs at a low cost,
is easy to set up,
does a fairly limited
number of things.
Apigee is a full featured
API management product
with a whole bunch of
complex enterprise features
like we've been
talking about now.
Over time, you know, both
Cloud Endpoints and Apigee
come from the same company
and the same group of people,
so over time, we're going to
make those things work together
more seamlessly.
Exactly what's going to happen
and when is not something
I can talk about right now.
But if you are using
Cloud Endpoints,
we'd actually love
to hear from you
as well because we're trying
to get some customer feedback.
Again, right now, they
serve different purposes
for different kinds of users.
And we want to make sure
that we respect all that.
KEITH DANEKIND: Thanks, Greg.
GREG BRAIL: There's
a question here.
The person is asking, we worked
in the past with a two layer
model where we
had an API gateway
on the edge communicating to
an internal API gateway that
did mediation,
composition, and so on.
Where does Apigee fit into this?
So is Apigee-- is it OK to
put these two things together?
So you could
certainly use Apigee
as a simple gateway
on the outside.
It can also do a lot
of this mediation stuff
so you saw when I
use a JavaScript
policy in the demo in there to
change the request to response,
do dynamic routing.
A lot of that can
be done in Apigee.
And it's really an architectural
choice about where you do that
and how that fits into
your organization.
People like that they can
quickly build things in Apigee.
I would say if you've
got full blown business
logic that's long
running and complicated,
put that behind Apigee.
If you've got
something that's going
to be stateless
and dynamic, that's
related to returning the right
format or something like that,
that's great to do in Apigee.
KEITH DANEKIND: Someone is
asking about baseline security
controls.
Do you have baseline
security controls
developed for Apigee
and VSI and kubernetes?
I don't know what
VSI is, but I will
say that we have a
security reporting thing
that we're working on.
I actually know--
I think it's alpha.
GREG BRAIL: Yeah,
it'll do a report on--
KEITH DANEKIND: But, I mean--
GREG BRAIL: --what
you've implemented.
KEITH DANEKIND: In terms
of your use of Apigee,
if you're a customer, we'd love
to talk to you more about that.
Because we're
looking at basically,
how do we tell you as
an Apigee customer,
you know, hey, you have security
policies about use of TLS
and things like that, and
you're not following them
in this particular API proxy.
And you can use that to help
make sure those things are
being enforced.
GREG BRAIL: Great, thanks.
So that's all the time we've
got for questions today.
I wanted to remind you
that-- speaking of security--
there's a Gartner Report
in the Resources tab,
and it's entitled How to Build
an Effective API Security
Strategy.
And you can download that
through the resources window
or on your screen.
Thank you so much
for attending today.
We'll see you in
the next webcast.
[MUSIC PLAYING]